[Applaudissements]
ce bol il est là parce qu'il représente
la vie ma propre vie mais aussi la vôtre
parce que comme dans la vie ben on peut
observer des motifs récurrents
l'intérieur des reflets parce que
parfois c'est comme si la vie elle nous
tendait un miroir il ya des
irrégularités des reliefs et des creux
parce que la vie c'est ça aussi c'est
fait de hauts et de bas dans l'ensemble
vous êtes d'accord la vie elle est
plutôt belle
la plupart du temps tout se passe bien
tout est fluide et comme ce bol tout est
lisse tout est rond tout est doux
seulement parfois tout se passe pas
exactement
problème de micro donc je recommence
peut-être non sérieux oui ok seulement
parfois tout se passe pas exactement
comme prévu
tout simplement parce qu'on peut pas
toujours tout prévoir on peut pas
toujours tout contrôler si vous décidez
d'avancer dans votre vie à tout moment
vous allez prendre des risques par
exemple en avançant peut-être le risque
de trébucher
et si vous vous retrouvez à jongler avec
tous les éléments de votre vie bah là
aussi vous allez prendre des risques le
risque de vous lancer et de vous
rattraper de justesse
finalement on est tous à la recherche de
la même chose c'est-à-dire un certain
équilibre
alors parfois cet équilibre on croit
qu'on va l'atteindre
on y est presque il tient à un fil
mais il tient alors ces moments on va
commencer à se détendre on va peut-être
même relâcher notre attention
allez on essaye juste une seconde mais
parfois on tombe parfois on se brise et
comme ce bol cassé en trois morceaux
nous avons tous des lignes de faille la
douleur c'est quelque chose qui est très
personnel parfois c'est une douleur
physique qu'on expérimente par exemple
un accident un handicap
le corps qui vieillit une maladie et
parfois c'est une douleur qui est plus
émotionnelle par exemple un licenciement
un deuil un divorce une dépression mais
quel que soit le type de souffrance
nous l'avons tous expérimenté sous une
forme ou sous une autre nous avons tous
des cicatrices
aujourd'hui je vous l'avez compris je
vais vous parler de douleur et de
souffrance mais je vous rassure aussi et
surtout de réparation et de résilience
alors la résilience en physique qu'est
ce que c'est c'est la capacité à
absorber les chocs et en psychologie
pour l'être humain c'est exactement la
même chose c'est la capacité à encaisser
les chocs de notre vie et à rebondir
reconstruire il ya un art qui symbolise
parfaitement l'esprit de la résilience
cet art s'appelle le kin ziggy alors
keane en japonais c'est lors du guide
c'est la jointure l'art de la jointure
alors c'est un art qui consiste à
souligner d'or les cicatrices d'un objet
cassé alors qu'on aurait pu décider de
les masquer ces réparations ou tout
simplement de le jeter à la poubelle et
c'est la parfaite métaphore de la
résilience parce que paradoxalement
l'objet devient plus beau plus fort et
plus précieux d'avoir été brisées et
pour nous en tant qu'être humain c'est
la même chose alors je vais vous le
prouver en vous posant tous ici une
petite question depuis que vous êtes né
en pourcentage à combien d'épreuves
difficiles avez-vous survécu jusqu'ici
en fait j'ai pas besoin de demander à
tous individuellement vous réponse parce
que la réponse est la même pour tout le
monde parce que si vous êtes là si vous
êtes vivant c'est que vous avez survécu
à 100% des épreuves de votre vie
jusqu'ici et parfois mêmes des cas où
vous avez pu en sortir grandi et ça
c'est le fameux ce qui ne me tue pas me
rend plus fort alors vous vous demandez
peut-être commencé tard a été inventée
qui a bien pu avoir un jour l'idée
saugrenue de mettre de l'or sur un objet
alors qu'on aurait pu décider de le
jeter à la poubelle
en fait c'est un arc qui date du 15ème
siècle au japon le shogun du japon c'est
à dire le chef des armées
ils utilisent tous les jours sont
baladés préféré un magnifique but
chinois
seulement un jour comme ce beau lui le
casse alors il décide de le renvoyer en
chine pour le faire réparer
il est prêt à attendre de longs mois
pour ça et vous imaginer à l'époque les
moyens de transport toute cette attente
et après tout ce temps le bol revient
avec la réparation dit des agrafes des
agrafes métalliques le long de la
fissure alors le problème c'est que non
seulement c'est assez visibles comme
réparation
c'est pas très discret mais en plus ça
ne résout pas du tout le souci départ
puisque le bol a toujours sa fille sûre
il n'est pas étanche
donc alors le shogun pas très content
demanda à ses artisans japonais trouver
de meilleures solutions et c'est ce
jour-là que l'art du clean juliénas
alors comme beaucoup d'autres arts
japonais c'est un arc extrêmement
minutieux et délicat qui rigoureux qui
demande beaucoup de préparation et
beaucoup de concentration
mais ce qui est vraiment merveilleux
avec les kings a glissé que au delà du
résultat final qui est vraiment fabuleux
qui nous parle qui parlent à notre
inconscient
chaque étape même de la réalisation d'un
quine ziggy et signifiante
parce que à chaque phase vous faites un
pas de plus vers votre propre guérison
alors ces étapes il y en a six je vais
vous les exposer les unes après les
autres parce que ça peut vous donner des
clés vers votre transformation si un
jour vous avez affronté une épreuve dans
votre vie alors la toute première étape
c'est celle on est comme ce bol brisé on
se sent sous le choc
on a même l'impression qu'on pourra
jamais réussir à se relever on est
littéralement c'est le cas de le dire en
mille morceaux
alors déjà la première chose à faire
c'est prendre un petit peu de recul sur
la situation
pour l'évaluer pour observer ou sont
moulées morceaux à combien il y en a
pour quoi il ressemble il s'agit de se
rassembler comme on ramasserait une à
une les pièces d'un puzzle corps étaient
éparpillés sur le sol
puis vient la deuxième étape ces salles
on commence à recoller les morceaux
alors on va rassembler les morceaux avec
le ca bis un mélange de farine est de là
qu on parlait d'un puzzle à l'instant
c'est comme un puzzle mais en 3d en
termes de guérison émotionnel c'est le
même principe c'est le moment vous
commencez à recoller les morceaux à
cicatriser à combler vos manques
seulement parfois comme sur cette photo
il peut nous manquer un morceau de notre
puzzle et dans ces cas là il faut pas
hésiter à les prendre sur un autre objet
pour l'intégrer à notre réparations
parce que ça signifie que dans la vie on
peut s'appuyer sur les autres pour se
reconstruire il faut même aller le
chercher sur un objet qui est encore
plus différent parce que ça va faire des
mélanges des mélanges très intéressant
qui défie l'imagination ou un plus un
égale 3 puis vient la troisième étape
c'est l'étape de la patience alors notre
objet on va le déposer délicatement dans
une boîte pendant plusieurs jours pour
le laisser sécher on fait très attention
parce que ces cicatrices elles sont
encore fraîches
alors c'est sûr qu'on aimerait tous
guérir nos douleurs nos souffrances en
un claquement de doigts en une seconde
en une séance
le king il est là aussi pour nous
rappeler que parfois il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que laisser le temps au
temps et c'est le temps faire son oeuvre
c'est pas forcément intuitif dans la
société dans laquelle on vit
actuellement au contraire tout plutôt
s'accélère qui de nos jours et encore
habitués à attendre que ce soit pour
chercher une information sur internet
pour télécharger un film ou une série
pour faire des rencontres
mais seulement ce qu'on a tendance à
oublier c'est que si on est trop
impatients les plaies qui sont encore
fraîches elles risquent de se rouvrir
voire même de s'infecter donc il faut
vraiment apprendre à ne pas brûler les
étapes et je vous invite à y réfléchir
pour vous est-ce que parfois dans votre
vie vous avez tendance à être un peu
trop impatient et à brûler les étapes
puis vient la phase numéro 4 c'est la
phase de la réparation est là on va
ressortir l'objet de la boîte
il a désormais bien sécher et on va
pousser chacune de ses lignes de faille
et on va mettre une première couche de
laque une couche de laque noire et elle
est très importante parce qu'elle va
rendre l'objet complètement étanche donc
ça va faire plaisir à notre shogun 2
tout à l'heure puis on va le nouveau le
déposer dans la boîte le laisser sécher
le ressortir leurs pensées et là on a
deuxième couche de laque une couche de
laque rouge
à quoi ça vous fait penser vous ces
belles lignes rouges bien brillantes
ça dépend des gens mais moi
personnellement ça me fait penser à un
réseau sanguin à des veines et c'est un
petit peu ça c'est comme s'il y avait la
vie qui revenait dans l'objet comme
s'ils étaient ranimés comme si son coeur
battait à nouveau et pour nous c'est la
même chose c'est le moment on se sent
prêt à revivre à remettre de la vie dans
notre vie a retrouvé un second souffle
et peut-être que nous aussi on a le
coeur qui bat à nouveau pour la première
fois depuis très longtemps parce que
maintenant on est prêts on est prêt pour
la phase numéro 5
c'est la face qu'on attendait depuis le
départ c'est le moment on va enfin
pouvoir mettre de l'or sur les blessures
donc sur la dernière couche de laque la
couche de laque rouge
elle est encore humide elle encore
fraîche on va saupoudré délicatement
de la poudre d'or pur et chaque
particule d'or va s'immiscer se mêler
intimement à la laque jusqu'à recréer
l'illusion d'une coulée d'or et pour
nous c'est un moment extrêmement fort
parce que c'est le moment des prêts à
éclore
on est on est prêt à reconnaître notre
valeur parce que nous aussi après tout
comme un qui y vivent nous méritons de
mettre de l'or pur sur nos blessures et
vient enfin l'étape 6 si l'étape finale
alors notre objet depuis le départ il a
été rassemblé pensée poncet cicatriser
recouvert d'or on l'a donc réunifiée
mais ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que
l'or c'est un métal et donc comme tous
mes talons peu le polir donc notre king
et on va le faire étinceler et là il va
émerger dans toute sa splendeur et pour
nous c'est ce moment très important on
est enfin prêt à assumer la beauté de
nos cicatrices et ça ça c'est pas anodin
parce que ça veut dire assumer la beauté
de notre passé la beauté de tout notre
parcours avec ses failles
c'est s'assumer dans sa globalité avec
ses forces et ses faiblesses
et comme un objet qui est passé par tout
le processus du kin ziggy toute cette
énergie réparatrice et à un moment où on
est prêt à s'exposer
moi si je suis là devant vous
aujourd'hui en train de m'exposer passé
que je suis arrivé à cette étape
alors moi personnellement ça m'a pris
deux ans deux ans jour pour jour parce
que c'est assez incroyable
c'était le 29 janvier 2017 que j'ai
découvert le kin ziggy pour la première
fois et je m'en souviens parce que je
l'avais noté parce que j'ai senti que ce
serait important même mais je ne savais
pas que ça allait m'emmener jusqu'ici ce
jour là alors faut remettre dans le
contexte de l'époque
quinze jours avant je venais d'apprendre
que j'allais divorcé à nouveau mon
deuxième divorce que j'allais me
retrouver seule avec mes deux filles a
élevé dont un bébé de quatre mois
donc vous imaginez dans quel état
émotionnel j'étais ce jour là par hasard
mais ce qui a vraiment que des asa
j'achète un magazine que je n'achète
jamais d'habitude
et pourquoi je l'achetais parce que sur
la couverture il décrit comment réussir
son divorce
donc ça m'a fait envie donc je l'ouvré
là je vois le mot qu'inzaghi j'en avais
jamais entendu parler mais là ya ma
petite voix intérieure
j'ai une sorte de frisson qui me
parcours qui me dis vas voir c'est
important pour toi il faut toujours
suivre son intuition
alors je suis allé voir j'ai tapé
qu'inzaghi sur internet et là j'ai vu
c'est magnifique ligne d'or qui me
parlait qui résonnait en moi c'est comme
si l'âme du kin ziggy elle est en
résonance avec la liane c'est comme si
c'est comme si je le connaissais déjà le
kin ziggy c'est comme si en voyant ces
lignes je me disais souviens-toi par le
passé a réussi à survivre à d'autres
épreuves peut-être même encore plus
difficile et là tu vas y arriver encore
et après j'ai découvert les six étapes
dont je vous ai parlé est là à chaque
étape il y avait des morceaux de moi qui
continuaient à se réparer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
jusqu'à ce bol ce bol il représente la
vie ma propre vie mais aussi la vôtre
avec toute la force de la résilience
moi je trouve que ce vol il est plus
intéressant qu avant il a une force en
lui la force de son parcours la force de
mon parcours il a la beauté de ses
imperfections
il est parfaitement imparfait comme moi
il me ressemble
alors maintenant je suis confronté à un
dilemme
parce que j'ai choix entre deux
solutions la première solution c'est que
ce bol je peux le mettre dans une
vitrine comme ça il sera bien protégé
pourra plus rien lui arriver
je pourrais le contempler tous les jours
et puis il ya une deuxième solution
en fait c'est celle que je préfère je
vous disais tout à l'heure j'ai tendance
à suivre mon élan et je sens que c'est
la solution qui m'attire le plus ce bol
je vais m'en servir tous les jours aider
c'est sûr que je vais prendre des
nouveaux risques le risque d'avancer
encore peut-être très
chez peut-être tomber peut-être me
casser me blesser encore mais maintenant
je sais que c'est pas grave parce que je
pourrai toujours remettre des nouvelles
lignes de faille en or et ce sera encore
plus beau finalement le qu'inzaghi c'est
un procédé quasi alchimique qui parle de
transmutation parce que comme en chimie
on cherche à révéler de façon éternelle
la beauté d'un objet comme le ferait un
élixir de longue vie est comme mon âge
chimie on cherche à changer notre propre
plomb en or le king il parle de
transformation de votre transformation
alors on ne sait pas de quoi l'avenir
est fait la vie on disait tout à l'heure
c'est fait de hauts et de bas
on peut rien prévoir je ne vous le
souhaite évidemment pas mais il est
possible que vous ayez affronté des
nouvelles difficultés dans votre vie si
c'était le cas je vous invite à vous
connecter à l'énergie du kin ziggy pour
rester optimiste pour vous souvenir que
vous aussi vous allez survivre choc de
votre vie vous aussi vous méritez de
mètres de leur pure sur vos blessures
vous aussi vous allez devenir plus beau
plus fort et plus précieux d'avoir été
brisées je vous invite véritablement à
transformer vos lignes de faille en
ligne de force
merci
[Applaudissements]